la guerra de las malvinas fue un
conflicto armado entre argentina y reino
unido- desataba en 1982 en el cual se
disputó la soberanía de estas islas
malvinas ubicadas en el atlántico sur
comenzó en abril con la ocupación del
puerto stand link por parte de las
tropas argentinas bajo órdenes de la
junta militar y como respuesta el
gobierno británico desplegó una enorme
fuerza que acabó en 10 semanas la
batalla y desalojó a las fuerzas
argentinas por completo la victoria
británica precipitó la caída de la
dictadura argentina y el inicio de la
recuperación del estado de derecho al
tiempo que contribuyó a la reelección
del gobierno conservador de margaret
thatcher esto en
1983 quiere salvar entonces a nuestro
segundo invitado el día del es felipe
pigna e historiador y profesor escritor
especializado en la historia argentina
gracias por estar con nosotros felipe
muy buen día bienvenido a directo
américa me pregunto entonces el balance
que podemos hacer en estos 40 años desde
que finalizó la guerra
bueno la verdad que la garra fuera una
locura no es lanzada por la dictadura
militar argentina con una enorme campaña
de propaganda la idea inicial era ocupar
las islas y hacer un reclamo ante
naciones unidas que fue bien recibido se
pudo haber negociado había disposición
incluso de parte de los eeuu de una
negociación de dos banderas o tres
banderas o sea en la tierra argentina
naciones unidas pero el dictador
galtieri se sintió fuerte con la
convocatoria malvinas siempre fue un
tema muy sensible para nosotros fue una
usurpación histórica de el imperio
británico por lo tanto la junta usó es a
esa cuestión sentimental y adquirir se
sintió fuerte en un momento de fuerte
crisis de la dictadura y decidió
quedarse algo que obviamente iba a
terminar mal porque era enfrentarse nada
más y nada menos que con gran bretaña
eeuu la otan no era imposible que
argentina gana si esa guerra más allá de
los actos periódicos que protagonizaron
los soldados según los oficiales
así que fue un hecho muy dramático que
consolidó desde mi punto de vista
sospechosamente la presencia británica
en las islas teniendo en cuenta las
excelentes relaciones que tenían
entonces
argentina al gobierno militar argentino
con gran bretaña con con eeuu con todo
lo que era el mundo neoliberal de
entonces
resulta bastante extraño en esta
operación enloquecida por parte de la
dictadura argentina en aquel momento
claro felipe y en actualidad digamos hay
realmente una unanimidad
sobre las malvinas en la población
argentina
se declaró si es un tema irrenunciable
para nosotros no albinas son argentinas
más allá de esta de esta locura que haya
cometido welter y las malvinas son y
fueron argentinas
la historia nos da la razón
fueron parte del imperio español todo
américa heredó las posesiones españolas
y argentinas que era una comandancia en
1829 que se dedicaba a combatir la
piratería británica y norteamericana que
consistía en cazar este valle de una
foca sin ningún tipo de permiso
depredando la zona y en 1833 los
ingleses ocuparon militarmente las islas
hasta
1982 ese breve periodo que contabas pero
durante todo ese tiempo de 1833 a 1982
la argentina reclamó ante todos los
foros
inglaterra se siento insegura muchas
veces de la de sus pergaminos para la
posesión de las islas no aquí tengo
documentos estela del propio farinós y
donde dice que éste no se sienten muy
muy seguros de esos derechos no donde
dicen que por ejemplo un funcionario del
foreign office no que fue de bernard a
la que se le pide
el informe dice es difícil evitar la
conclusión de que la actitud del
gobierno argentino no es enteramente
injustificada y que nuestra acción ha
sido algo despótica nuestra posición
tiene ciertas debilidades pero nosotros
hemos ocupado en las islas durante más
de un siglo y por razones estratégicas
no podemos renunciar a ellas de manera
que lo más indicado es adaptar una línea
dura no
es decir que ellos mismos reconocen que
sus pergaminos diplomáticos son muy
débiles las fuerzas lo que los ha
sostenido pero el gobierno argentino
luego de nuestra argentinos a lo largo
de los siglos han reclamado
permanentemente de forma pacífica e
inclusive naciones unidas nos de la
razón en 1965 cuando invitó aa negociar
en la resolución 2065 de naciones unidas
invitó a negociar a la violenta nia y
argentina la disputa de soberanía felipe
le quiero preguntar si esta disputa y
estos reclamos son algo más de como de
poder digamos entre los países como como
diego en dónde llegamos al 1 cd parte
del reino unido no soltar a malvinas de
parte argentina de seguir reclamando la
no algo no de parte de la tierra es una
histórica posición colonial es casi el
último enclave colonial que tiene gran
bretaña en el mundo uno de los pocos que
quedan y de parte argentina es un
reclamo histórico al que no vamos a
renunciar nunca las malvinas son
argentinas y están ocupadas con una
potencia extranjera lo cual también nos
da la razón gran parte de américa cuando
en cualquier foro internacional los
países americanos con excepción de los
eeuu nos dan la razón de que las
malvinas son argentinas y gran parte del
mundo cuando hay una resolución
expresiones unidas las votaciones son
prácticamente unánime para que se
discuta nuevamente la soberanía sobre
malvinas pudiera algún momento las
malvinas ser parte de argentina osa
digamos tener el control soberano de
argentino en las malvinas para va a ser
difícil porque hay una base militar
inglesa tremenda no la demo empresa yo
estuve malvinas es un ya es una zona
ocupada por por una base de la otan ya
no de no sólo de gran bretaña donde hay
más población es la base que él
en el pueblo que nosotros llamamos
puerto argentino y los ingleses puerto
stanley hay 2.400 habitantes en la base
y 1800 en el en el pueblo así que es un
enclave militar tremendo porque
recordemos que malvinas en muchas cosas
no es una potencia extraordinaria a
nivel pesquero del krill del calamar del
langostino son miles de millones de
libras que vienen explotando hace muchos
años es un lugar entre un paso
interoceánico al único paso
interoceánico natural entre el atlántico
y el pacífico es magallanes el canal de
panamá eso se construyó mucho después y
por eso los ingleses trataron de
preservar el dominio sobre malvinas
malvinas proyecta soberanía sobre la
antártida en el momento que se discuta
la soberanía antártica inglaterra va a
querer aprovechar esa proyección para
quedarse con una porción importante de
la antártida así que son muchas las
cosas por las cuales inglaterra no
quiere soltar más largas no solamente no
es una cuestión de evo nada más sino que
sobre todo es una cuestión económica
estamos hablando de una zona riquísima
por la potencialidad petrolera y muy
particularmente por la potencialidad y
la realidad pesquera
así las viven y los habitantes tienen un
altísimo nivel de vida pues son pocos de
los derechos de pesca no que son
multimillonarios en dólares o en libras